SHARAD JONES: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're going
to be talking about lambda.
So in the last video--
I'm sorry, I'm sliding myself.
I'll just stop moving.
In the last video, we talked
about machine learning and all
the ways that we may want
to or need to leverage cloud
computing for machine learning.
And I mentioned lambda as kind
of an example of something I use
personally for collecting data.
And I want to walk
through now what
lambda is in a bit more detail.
And again, I gave kind
of a high-level overview,
but I want to show
you this in detail
just so you get a sense for how
versatile of a tool this is.
As far as commonly used AWS
tools are for me at least,
I put obviously S3, EC2
up there towards the top
as far as straightforward
useful resources in the Cloud.
Lambda is up there as
the third tier for me.
That's the next thing
that I'd probably
say if I needed
something or if I
was going to leverage
the Cloud, I'd
probably end up using Lambda
for something before, honestly,
a lot of the other tools
we've even seen so far.
And again, that's obviously
given my background and the type
of projects I'm
working on, but it's
such a versatile and useful
tool that I want you to see it.
So let's just dive
into it right away
so we can get some context
for why it is so valuable.
So at a high level,
as I mentioned before,
Lambda is a serverless
compute service.
So what that means is that I am
not spinning up EC2 instances
explicitly.
I'm not actually determining
the amount of resources
I need to do a specific task.
I basically just define my code.
I come up with the code
for my task at hand.
I upload it to
the Lambda service
or basically I create
a Lambda function,
which houses my code in it.
And then either
based off of events
or I can run on a
schedule every night,
every day, whatever it is,
I will kick off this lambda
function and then
it'll just run it.
So to me as a user,
I actually don't even
have to think about this
as a Cloud infrastructure
that's being used.
How much time is it taking?
I don't worry about that at all.
All I think about is
I want this task done.
And I don't want to
do it on my computer.
Therefore, I write
the Lambda function,
deploy it there, and it
runs at the pace that I need
or on the schedule that I need
or for the events that I need.
That level of
hands off is really
what again can start to make
the Cloud such a useful tool.
The more that we have to
get in the weeds with it,
the less valuable
it starts to become,
the more headaches we have
debugging and all that stuff,
as you all have seen.
But I just want to try to get us
or introduce us to these tools.
Anytime you see a
serverless service, that
is what we're really
talking about,
is you're removing all of that
management away from yourself.
So again, upload your code,
deploy a Lambda function,
runs on a schedule or
in response to events.
Only runs when it's triggered.
And again, you only pay
for the time that you use.
So if you're not using any-- if
you're not running the function,
you're not paying for it.
It's not like something
where, with the EC2 instance,
if I have it up, I have to
remember to stop it and all that
or terminate it.
None of that matters.
I only pay for it
when I'm using it.
So I can just set up the
function, deploy it, and then
I don't have to worry that
I'm all of a sudden running up
the cost, unless I'm
triggering a bunch of events
or if there's a
bunch of computations
that have to be done.
So as far as pros
and cons go then,
pros by far one of the
best things about it
is that it supports multiple
different programming languages.
So we're going to
use it obviously
in Python, given that that's
what we teach for the most
part in our department.
But it encompasses a bunch
of other tools and languages
or better statement
can work directly
with those other languages too.
So if you're coding in C++, you
can just deploy your function
directly in that language.
You don't to rewrite
it into something else
or worry about that.
It just knows how to
interpret that language.
And I don't have the exact
list, but if you just
go to Lambda site, you'll see
obviously the listing there.
And we'll see when we
do a demo of what we
have available for ourselves.
The other thing
again is completely
automated administration.
So we don't have to worry
about it, like being
the admins of our
services, we don't
have to start anything like
that, worry about instances.
It just handles itself.
Built-in fault tolerance.
So it's doing these
computations itself
across multiple
availability zones
to protect against any sort
of individual machine or data
center failures.
So when I kick off my Lambda
function, unbeknownst to me,
it's going to be running
in multiple locations
so that I can avoid
any of those risks.
So again, completely
managed serverless service.
You're not worrying
about any of that at all.
You can orchestrate multiple
functions as well too.
So you can have one function
kick off another function.
They can sync up and
do things together.
So very flexible toolkit that
again, we pay per usage for.
So it's billed in
increments of I
think milliseconds or
something like that.
So again, we're only going to be
paying for exactly what we need.
Actually, for that
matter, we could
and we'll pull it up in a
second here the pricing on that.
But that is kind of the
consideration for it.
Now, as far as cons go,
everything has downsides.
For one, it's not really--
I don't want to say--
I think not suitable for
small projects is maybe
a bit harsh of a statement.
It's just that it's a little
bit overkill for small projects.
Like we'll see, for example,
when we build our own Lambda
functions, if I'm just
doing something one time,
I don't really need to
worry about being scheduled
or something like that.
It's not really worth setting
up as a Lambda function.
It's going to take me just
as much time to create it,
debug it as it would to
just spin up an EC2 instance
and do the task.
So instead, I really want to
keep these reserved for cases
where I need to do something
at scale or in a way
that I really am going to be
repeating this process over
and over again.
I don't want to have to
manage that orchestration.
You'll also need
to know in advance,
or at least that may
be a debugging step.
And actually in preparation
for one of the future demos,
I forgot this
point, but you need
to have a sense of the memory
needs of your function.
So when we deploy
this function, it's
going to have a set minimum
or maximum memory like RAM
that it utilizes.
And also it'll have
a timeout command.
So if it runs for I think
longer than a few seconds,
it'll just assume
that maybe it's broken
and I should shut it down,
such that I'm not charging you
for all the seconds
that it's live.
And that's a great
feature to have.
But also if my function actually
does take a long time to run,
like I know it's going to
take on the order of minutes,
I need to make sure I
give it the capacity
to be able to run for minutes
so that I don't have that issue.
Now, the risk is
obviously if I set it
for just infinite amount of
time as far as the timeout,
then I could be
charged continuously
for something that could
quickly run up in costs.
So that balancing act
is necessary still.
And then finally, you are
still constrained to only run
your commands in code.
So you can't-- and this
is easily behind my head.
You couldn't just go
and say, OK, well,
I need to do something
in Microsoft Word
and grab that and upload
it or something like that.
You're not going
to be orchestrating
or being able to tie together a
bunch of external applications.
Everything you do is
going to be in code.
So if it's something where
you're still learning,
you're kind of going through the
process of understanding Python,
how to code in Python, this
might not be the tool for you
yet.
But as you start to
understand a coding language
or if you have that
experience, then this
can be a really great resource.
But again, you will need
to do everything in code.
So considerations.
So then as far as what can
trigger a Lambda function,
I think first off, the easiest
to explain is not listed here,
but the easiest to understand
would be just using
some sort of schedule, is if I
have a scheduled event that--
and we'll see how
to set that up,
where every night it has to
run or every 10 seconds I need
to run or maybe every day
at 3:00 and 5:00 PM it runs,
that is the easiest one to do.
And it basically will
send off an alert.
And I believe it uses
Amazon's EventBridge service
to kick off those events.
And that will trigger-- or that
can trigger a Lambda function.
So you can set it up such that
it triggers on the schedule.
But I think arguably
more interesting
are all the other ways that
we can trigger a function.
So for example, entry
into an S3 bucket.
So upload, deletion, moving
of a file, any of those things
can technically
send off a trigger.
Meaning that again,
if somebody maybe
uploads a file to my S3 bucket.
Maybe you guys are students.
Maybe if we did this,
and I could do this,
for example, for a project.
Maybe I say when you are
done with your assignment,
upload it to this S3 bucket.
And then every
time the S3 bucket
gets a new file into there,
I could trigger an AWS Lambda
function that would then
maybe go and check to see if--
and let's tie this
into machine learning.
Maybe it would look to see
if your screenshot looks
like the screenshot of
a A, B, a C, or a D.
And it classifies A, B, C, or D.
I could set up a function
that does that, assuming I
have trained a model that
can make that prediction.
But let's imagine we
have this magic black box
that taking as input a
screenshot of your website
can predict the grade.
Well, then maybe I
could, again, when
you upload your file
to the S3 bucket,
it triggers my Lambda function.
It runs and it immediately
scores your assignment,
and then returns to me a JSON
file or maybe pushes it to--
the Lambda function is
again just Python code.
So I could have a
push to a database.
I could probably even
find a way to sync it up
with Canvas honestly, such
that Canvas automatically
gets an uploaded grade.
So all these things are
now at your disposal.
Anything you can think
about piping together,
as long as you can do it
in code, you can do it.
And again, it can be triggered
by S3 bucket actions.
Similarly, insertions
in a DynamoDB table.
So DynamoDB is a NoSQL database.
So if some of the adds,
updates, deletes data
in this database, same thing.
I can trigger an
AWS Lambda function.
And again, this is assuming
everything's running
in the Cloud.
It's all set up.
Then yeah, you can
do it that way.
There's also Amazon simple
notification service.
So it's used for
push notifications.
So if I have a
service maybe where
I'm trying to think of
an example now coming up
with business ideas on the fly.
But maybe I send push
notifications from my app
that's hosted in AWS to my
customer, or I want to--
or I want to send an SMS, a text
message to a customer or I'm
doing some sort of
political polling
and I'm texting every person
that's a registered voter.
I'm sure some of you
received those recently,
that can be also used
as a trigger then.
So when there's an event in the
simple notification service,
so sending a text message
out to the phone number,
and actually for
that matter, we can
send messages using simple
notification services
to the phone number
using AWS Lambda.
Either a vice versa, you
can trigger lambda events.
API Gateway is just a
fully managed service
for creating APIs.
So we obviously built our
APIs using Flask directly.
But there is a managed
service for creating APIs.
And so we can set up that such
that any sort of requests--
GET requests, PUT
requests, those
can trigger Lambda functions.
We can use CloudFront, which is
AWS's content delivery network.
So if you're hosting
your website,
maybe using the
Lambda@Edge feature,
if there's some sort
of header request.
So you remember how we had
like the question mark equals
something or question
mark ID equals
something or other in the URL.
So there's some sort of request
that gets passed in the header,
I can have Lambda process that
can trigger a Lambda function.
There's so many things
you can keep listing here.
Kinesis, CloudTrail, all
these different things
can trigger off
Lambda functions.
So the moral of the story
is for the most part,
for anything you
can come up with,
you can usually find a way to
string together something such
that it triggers your
Lambda function based off
of surrounding
events in the Cloud.
And that is really what gives
us a lot of value in this.
So at a high level,
the way that looks then
is you'll have your
function code right,
you'll have some
sort of dependency.
So maybe these
are like packages.
Like maybe I'm using Pandas
or NumPy if I'm in Python.
And those will need to be
tagged along or passed along
to my Lambda function in a way.
And we'll talk about
how they do that.
And then also we'll have
some sort of execution role.
IAM role that gives
permissions to do that task.
And so my AWS Lambda
function is going
to be comprised of all of this.
And once I define
my Lambda function,
I'm going to use
lambda to deploy that.
And so I can run my code.
When it's trigger, I
can set up the trigger.
Either I can
manually test it or I
can set up the schedule
or event-based triggers.
And then it can also use
Amazon's CloudWatch tool
and we'll see how that works as
well to view logs and metrics
and monitor it and see, well,
how long did the last Lambda
function call run for?
How long did or how much
did the most recent call
cost me as far as dollars?
All those things can be
observed in CloudWatch.
Trying to make sure I didn't
miss anything in my notes.
A few other things
to note, though.
So we add a trigger.
We add our function code.
Again, like I said, we do need
to specify the memory as well
too.
So how much memory we're going
to allocate to this function.
Could be anywhere
from 128 megabytes up
to about 10 gigabytes.
So a decently large
instance effectively
is what you're allowing.
10 gigabytes should be
enough for most simple tasks.
If it's larger than
that, you're probably
going to be doing it
in another way anyways.
Maybe you need to set
up a little application
or build a little
web application
and run that on an
EC2 instance or using
one of these other
managed services.
But 10 gigabytes will
get you a long way.
And Yeah, either way you
zip up all this information
here, the
dependencies, the code,
and everything into a
nice little deployment
package and that is
what Lambda uses then.
So when the event
is triggered, it's
basically going to grab
this code, this zip file,
unzip it, spin up the
relevant instances,
install the relevant
libraries, run your code,
and then shut it
back down again.
So you only pay for the
time that it's live,
that it's actually
executing your code.
So some examples of that then.
So this is kind of what a
schedule-based event would
look like.
So let's say you have--
you're working for a
company, small business,
and you all have a
bunch of EC2 instances.
You're using Cloud resources.
Well, you realize that people
are leaving their EC2 instances
live.
Hint, hint.
If you have your
EC2 instances live,
make sure to shut those down.
We're not needing those anymore.
But either way, you have
your EC2 instances live.
And then every day,
rather than having
to worry about going in there
and manually shutting them
down and then also
similarly starting them
back up again in
the morning just
so your users can
log in and not have
to worry about being managers
or doing any sort of IT work
as far as starting and
stopping their services,
well, we can set up some events.
So we could set up a CloudWatch
scheduled event or sorry,
it's going to be
EventBridge now.
It used to be CloudWatch.
So a lot of documentation
still says CloudWatch,
but I think they migrated
all that over to EventBridge.
But either way, I could set
up an event to say, well,
at 10:00 PM every
night in my local time,
I want to trigger
this Lambda function.
In this lambda
function, I've given it
the IAM role such that it
is allowed to start and stop
EC2 instances.
And so it'll spin up
some Python code maybe,
and that Python code will
run basically the commands
from Python using
the AWS packages,
but it'll run those
commands to shut down,
to stop all instances
that are running live.
And then every night
that runs automatically.
And then I could say, well, at
5:00 AM, I want to reverse this.
I'll use the same IAM role.
I'll just set up a different
Lambda function now
that triggers to
start the services.
And so in--
It'll take me a few
minutes to set up.
I can automatically manage
starting and stopping
my EC2 instances without
having to go in there
and manually change each one.
Or you can recognize
that because again, we
could by all means, have some
sort of hibernation setting on
or set the hibernation
function or option when we're
starting our EC2 instances.
But we might have
a bunch of users
creating many
different EC2 instances
for a variety of reasons.
And so this way, I don't even
have to worry about, hey,
did I make sure that
every person set up
their EC2 instance correctly
to have hibernation on?
Instead, just every night, I
list out all the EC2 instances
in my account to stop them.
And then in the morning, I
start all them back up again.
And again, you can do any number
of variations of this process,
but that's the basic idea.
Alternatively, let's say we
had something where we were-
and this is, again, more
often how I've used it.
But maybe we had something where
we're collecting a bunch of data
or downloading a
bunch of images,
or we host a bunch of
images on our website.
Maybe we are kind of a
Facebook style company
where we have a website that
houses a bunch of images on it.
Well, I need to have a thumbnail
version of all my images
because I don't want to have to
load the full image every time
it shows up on a search
page or something like that.
So a user goes and uploads
maybe this is my web app here.
The step 1 here is
them using my web app.
So step 1, they use
my web app, they
upload their image, their
full resolution image.
I dump that into the S3 bucket.
Well, the second I have
something added to this S3
bucket, I've set up or I
can set up a trigger such
that it kicks off
this Lambda function.
And this Lambda function
maybe says, OK, great, well,
what I need to do is I'm
given this execution role that
allows me to access S3 buckets.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to come in here
and I'm going to take
my full size image
and I'm just going to
downsample it and create
a small thumbnail version.
I can do that in
Python really easy.
You just use the pillow
library or other similar image
manipulation library.
But I'm going to take
the full size image,
downsize it so it's just a
little 64 by 64 pixel image.
And then I'll upload
that to my other bucket.
That's my thumbnails bucket.
So that way, whenever they
come back to the website,
I've set up these names,
maybe the file names
such that I know that this is
the file that should show up
there, but I pulled the
thumbnail version of it,
so it just displays all
the thumbnails on the page,
loads much faster.
Then when they click
on it, my web app
says, OK, well if they
clicked on this link,
I'm going to load up
the full size image.
Now grab that one from S3.
But that's a different issue.
That's a separate project.
Here we're just saying
they upload a photo,
we trigger a Lambda action
or a Lambda function.
That Lambda function creates
a thumbnail and dumps
that back into a new bucket.
And again, all of
this is completely
orchestrated via Lambda.
I don't have to go in
here manually do this.
I don't have to set up another
function outside of Python
or outside using Python
that tries to call into this
and do this automatically.
It's just built into AWS.
So really, really nice
feature, very easy to set up.
And so a high level then,
last point on this before we
look at a quick demo,
Lambda has a couple limits.
They have both kind of soft
limits and hard limits.
So the soft limits are
that basically saying
that if you want something
beyond this capacity,
you have to send in support
ticket with justification
and you could potentially
get these relaxed.
These hard limits are
just built into lambda.
You can't ever exceed these.
So, for example, the
soft limits here,
1,000 concurrent executions.
That means 1,000 lambda
executions at the same exact
time.
If you want to exceed
that, which is a lot.
You're going to be running
up some charges pretty quick.
But if you want to, you can let
them know and they will do that.
But this is one way
they can potentially
avoid any sort of nefarious
behavior with Lambda functions.
For example, you don't want
to be able DDoS somebody out
of nowhere with this just
because you're spinning up
a bunch of concurrent
executions.
Similarly, 75 gigabytes of
function in layer storage.
So this is saying
like the physical disk
space it takes up for
all of the function code
that you have written for
your Lambda function, as well
as the layer.
The layer is how we actually
upload all of the dependencies.
And so libraries, Pandas,
NumPy, all the other Boto3,
any other package you need
to use for your Python code
to execute, that would be
wrapped into your layer.
So if you have more than
75 gigbytes of storage
necessary for all
of that, then you
need to reach out to them
to have that pushed up.
I would argue that
you really you're
not going to need more than
this for most reasonable tasks.
You're going to be
such an advanced level
before you realize that
you might need actually
more than this.
And in that sense,
there's probably also more
cost effective tool to use for
that, versus the hard limits.
These are, again,
fixed in place.
You're not going to even
be able to extend these.
So, for example, the
10 gigabytes of memory.
The memory being the RAM on
that, that's necessary for that
function to run.
If you need more than
10 gigs of RAM again,
I would argue you
probably shouldn't
be using Lambda as a tool.
It's meant for really
small, quick actions.
You don't want to have
it spin up a whole thing
and run this really, really
long process in Lambda.
There's some much more cost
effective ways to do that.
So 10 gigabytes is
usually sufficient.
The 15 minutes before
a timeout, it again
is to avoid things that are
way too large for Lambda
and also avoid the
risk of infinite costs
just running up here because
I don't want a function.
Maybe I kick off
500 Lambda functions
to run it once or 500 concurrent
executions of my Lambda function
to do the thumbnail processing.
Well, maybe there's
some bug in my code
that causes an infinite loop
and all 500 of those just start
running forever.
That could get really
expensive really fast.
And so they set that 15
minutes really for your safety
to say if it's beyond
this, you probably
don't want to be doing
this in Lambda anyways.
The 250 megabyte unzip
deployment package,
that is saying--
and actually this--
sorry, this is clarifier,
this 75 gigabytes of function
layer storage I believe
is across all of your
Lambda functions.
So like the permanent
persistent layers of storage.
This is not for a single app.
So I misspoke there.
Because this is actually the how
big your deployment package size
is.
You can see here, unzipped your
deployment package can only be
250 megabytes, which
is actually still
usually sufficient
for most things
you need, but much
smaller than 75 gigabytes.
So sorry for
misquoting that there.
But either way, 250 megabytes.
And you'll actually
see this because if you
try to upload a layer, we'll
see when we do that step, what
uploading a layer--
the zip file for the
layer looks like.
It'll tell you this exceeds 250.
Well, you can't create
this layer this way.
Again, the reason being
is that Lambda functions
are designed to spin up
really, really quickly.
And so if I have
to do this, if this
is larger than 250
megabytes, it's
going to take a
long time to just
spin it up, unzip it, install
all the packages and everything
like that.
So they have to keep this small.
It's kind of the same as when
we deploy to Heroku, when
we deployed our web app
there, they I think,
max you out around
three or 500 megabytes
for your deployment package
size for the same reason.
You don't want to have
it just sitting there.
And then finally, if you
have a much larger workload,
you can actually
deploy your container
or your Lambda function
to a container image.
So that is kind of expanding
what you can do on your--
or for your Lambda function.
Oops.
But that container image can't
be larger than 10 gigabytes.
So again, a similar kind
of constraint there.
So that's kind at a high
level a quick, quick overview
of what AWS Lambda is.
What I want to do now
is I'm going to pause
and I'm going to
switch gears and we're
going to transition to
looking at running through it,
just a really quick
demo of this tool.
All right.
So picking up then, I've just
opened up the AWS console,
obviously.
So if you want to follow along,
you're more welcome to do this.
This should be running
in the free tier.
So you are welcome to try to run
it on your university account.
But again, for
consistency, I'm just
recommending moving
forward, doing everything
on your personal account.
Seems to be a bit too unstable
with this many people trying
to do everything
without us being
running kind of in a better
managed corporate account.
So this is, again,
a different topic
for another day of the ease of
setting this up and running this
at scale, a lot of different
people on the same account.
In reality, what we should have
is an organizational account
that has much better defined
roles and constrained
capacities.
But from a learning standpoint,
it's much easier for me
to try to give you more access.
But that also then
limits what you can do.
So trade-offs,
learning, growing pains.
Either way.
For now, for
consistency, you probably
want to run this
on your personal.
But if for whatever
reason, you don't have one
or couldn't get it working,
feel free to try it
on the university account.
Just make sure again to
always delete everything
after you're done.
So either way, once you
come here, as always,
you can either search it up here
or search up here for lambda
or click it if it's right
there on the main page.
So you're going to do that.
Open up the Lambda page.
And so right now,
there's actually a bunch
of functions already created.
One of these is
the one we're going
to do in the next video,
this code scraping one.
But if you don't have
this or if you're
doing this on your personal
account, it'll look different.
It'll just be nothing here.
And it's fine.
You can just click
Create function.
That's what we're
going to do anyways.
So you can see here now
under the create function,
we can either create a
new function from scratch,
use a blueprint, or
select a container image,
as we talked about.
For again, this first
quick demo, we're
just going to use a blueprint.
And so I think the one
we wanted to use, yeah.
So let's look for
the hello world one.
Everybody loves a
good hello world.
It's called hello world Python.
And so we'll just click that,
and then we'll click Configure.
So again, as you can
see, this is just
building a lambda application
from some sample code.
And actually, you can see
there's a bunch of other things
you can do or select as
far as pre-built ones.
Book a trip with Lex,
handle Slack slash commands.
So without even writing
all the code, all of these
already exist.
I mean, you see there's
multiple pages of this 46
different blueprints.
So if you want to
explore that as well too,
you'd be surprised what's
already pre-built in there.
But we'll just do this
hello world one for now
and click Configure.
And then in there, we can
name it whatever we want.
So, I mean, I'll just call
it hello world Python.
Why not?
And you see, it's going to
create a execution role for us
by default.
It's going to give it
permission to upload logs
to Amazon CloudWatch Logs.
If that's sufficient, what
we're doing, which for this one,
it is, I believe.
I think we need to give
it any other permissions.
All right, let's do it.
Actually, let's do create a new
role from AWS policy templates.
But either way, if you did
need more permission than that,
you could leave it at that.
If you've already made a
role for your function,
you can select it here, or
you can do create a new role.
And so I'll call this one
just lambda_basic_execution.
And then I think--
I don't think we
need to actually
give it any more,
because what we're saying
is that we don't need it to
have access to anything else.
So I'm just trying
to double check
over my notes to make sure
I didn't miss anything.
These are also-- these should
be on Canvas as well too,
under Lecture 23 Lambda Demo.
But yeah, either way.
I think we're fine
without anything else
because we're not
going to actually call
to any external services.
But either way, this is
what the sample code looks
like for this specific one.
We'll see in a second
where we can edit it,
but for now, we're
just looking at it.
This is what's kind of
pre-baked into this.
So once we come down here and
click Create Function, oops,
I already have that role.
So either way, I
already have this role.
So I'm going to do
use an existing role
and just do the
lambda_basic_execution.
But if you don't have that,
you can create a new one.
So it's just creating
a role as we've always
done it before with IAM roles.
OK.
So now we find ourselves in the
actual main in the main code
or the main words.
The main console window.
There we go, for the
Lambda functions.
So OK, we can click OK on that.
And so you can see
here, first off,
this is just kind
of where we see
any triggers that are
associated with our function
or any destinations.
This is our function itself.
If we had any layers, which
we'll see the next time,
we could click here
and it would drop us
down here to add on the layers.
And this would be again
adding in any sort
of dependencies or packages
associated with this.
You can see here as well
the runtime settings.
So this is where it's
actually running.
So it's going to be
running in a Python 3.7.
The Handler, as
you see here, this
is which Handler method
is going to be invoked
by running this
function for what we're
going to do in this one
and actually the next one,
we can leave this as default.
But conceivably, you
could change that.
Again, all this is
saying is that we're
going to basically run the code
that's in this window right
here, and that's OK.
And then you can also
change the architecture.
So if you're running an ARM
architecture versus x86,
you can do that as well.
But for now, we just want
to look at this window
because this is really
just a Python editor.
We could add any code
we wanted to in here
and save it and all
that good stuff.
Once you save your
changes, you do
need to click Deploy so
that those changes are
updated with the function here.
And so yeah, if you can see
here, what this code basically
is doing is it is going to take
as input some event and context.
And this is going to be
based off of the trigger that
kicked it off.
So we're going to simulate
a trigger here and just pass
a test function to it
or a test trigger to it.
But if you had scheduled this
in some way, then that is going
to contain the relevant
information that's
passed to here, or if there's
something else that calls to it
or that triggers the S3
function or something like that,
that can also pass extra
information in this context
as well or this
event as well too.
So this is just, again, the
way the structure of this code.
And so again, you see here
lambda_function.lambda_handler,
lambda_function.lambda_handler.
So that's what's
running or that's
what's going to run when
we kick off this function.
If we change this
to something else,
if we define a new
function, we just
need to make sure we
change that down there too.
So now to test it
to see how it works,
we'll come over here, click
this little dropdown arrow
and click Configure Test Event.
And we're just going
to create a new event.
We're just going
to call it, I don't
know TestEvent doesn't matter.
We'll leave it private.
Though if you're working
in with a group or a team,
you can make it shareable
such that anybody
in your account
who has permissions
could see these test events.
So if you're working with a
team that's testing functions,
this is a great thing
to do, because you
can share these test events.
And we'll use this template
because this is the one that's
kind of pre-baked with this.
But we'll see in the
future that this is just
basically the format of
the way it's triggered.
So all of these are
different potential triggers
with different
information in them.
And so, for example, if I--
let me just say I clicked--
I don't know, S3 put.
You can see here that this
is the event JSON that gets
passed to it for a put action.
So if a put action
in my S3 bucket
is the trigger
for this function,
then this is what it would
look like most likely.
It's something resembling this.
And so this is
information that I
could use in my
call, what was put
into here, the bucket, the size
of the object, all that stuff.
And so by using this
sample code here,
I can simulate what my function
will do if that happens.
But for now, again,
we're just going
to take the
recommended hello world
because it's expected that we
have three keys and values.
This kind of dictionary.
So let's say, for
example, that I replaced
the first key with hello world.
Then we'll just click Save.
Well, now if I go down here
and click Test, it should-- oh,
it got.
There we go.
No execution results yet.
Let's try this again.
Did I not save it?
Save, deploy.
Now let's try testing it.
There we go.
And now you can see the
kind of logs of this.
This is what the execution
results will look like.
And so this will tell you what's
happening in your function.
So you can see we
ran this test event.
The response was hello
world, because that's
what the response
of this function is.
But more importantly,
we can see here
in these function
logs that we took in,
we can see we have these
print statements here.
These print statements
are taking in the event
and they're looking
for key 1 and event.
So event is that JSON file
that we passed because key 1--
or sorry.
Yeah, key 1 in there
was hello world.
And so now you can see this
is how I can pass information
from my event trigger to
Python to then execute on.
So again, had this
been my S3 put call,
then I could have
passed information
about the file and the
size and all that to Python
to then do something with it.
Downsize it and we talked
about the thumbnail.
Maybe I want to shrink it
and then upload it again.
So all of that can
be defined like this.
We could also look
into the metrics here.
So if we come over
here, click monitor.
I don't think we actually gave
it permissions to see this.
Let's see.
Yeah, we didn't give it
permissions to see this.
But had we done that and
we'll see that in the next one
because we'll give it
permissions to do this.
You'll see how many
invocations, how many times
was this function invoked,
the duration of each of them,
the error count, the
success rate failures,
how many concurrent executions?
All this information
will show up in here.
All these logs will
show you, again,
the most expensive invocations.
So you can see here this one was
the most expensive invocation.
It took two milliseconds.
It's built in duration
of gigabits seconds.
So 0.00025.
We can actually really quick
also look at Lambda pricing.
So we said we were
going to do that.
So you can see that--
well, actually, first
off, there is a free tier.
I forget what the free
tier is. look in a second.
But for x86 calls, you're paying
0.000016667 for every gigabit
second.
And so here we have
gigabit seconds.
So 0.00025.
So it's 0.00025 five
times 0.000016667.
And so technically, that
would have cost us 4 times 10
to the negative 9 dollars.
So very cheap.
I mean, you can see here, that's
for duration and the number
$0.20 per 1 million requests.
So these prices are super low.
And that's really the value
of this, is that I mean,
even though this
is not running--
even if it wasn't
running at the free tier,
it still is wildly cheap.
I'm pretty sure, again, that
they have a free tier for this,
though.
Let's see, lambda free tier.
So the lambda free tier includes
400,000 gigabit seconds of time
every month.
So you can use this again
in many different ways,
or for that matter, you can
even host a website via Lambda
is that when somebody sends a
request to your URL or whatever,
you can have it kick off
a Lambda function that
returns a file and posts there.
And you could do that
as long as it's static.
So this is again the
flexibility of lambda
here, super cheap to run as long
as you're not doing something
at a large or of
absurdly large scale.
But even then, it's a while
before you run into any issues.
So that's mostly it.
Last thing, I'll just
show you how to delete it.
You just click Actions, click
Delete Function, click Delete.
And it's that easy.
Again because there's not any
sort of instances running live,
it spins it up and shuts
it down serverless.
And so you don't have to worry
that there's this long thing
to shut down or a bunch of
things to sync together.
It's just that one function.
So we'll leave it at
that for this video.
We'll pick up kind of
from here next time
and actually look at a
more like in-depth example
of doing something with it.
Again, got this hint here.
We're going to be
scraping some COVID
data using a Lambda function.
So hopefully,
that's a good teaser
for the next video, which will
be, I believe, next week then.
So we'll see you next time.
Let me know if you
have any questions,
and talk to you later.